[Music]  Jimmy Fallon answering to his critics  and shutting it down  rumors very lucky I have The Tonight  Show so I host the show every night  Fallon gets real and a new New York  Times profile addressing the New York  Post's 2016 claim that network execs  were concerned about his drinking habits  quote I could never do a day-to-day job  if I was drinking every night  that's just kicking you when you're down  he also talks the backlash effaced for  this interview with now president Donald  Trump go ahead with my hair spa  [Applause]  [Music]  well they have a right to be mad if I  let anyone down it hurt my feelings that  they didn't like it I didn't mean  anything by it I was just trying to have  fun